כן.
quantum circuit הוא יחידת הערך
לעסק שלך, ה-qubit הוא יחידת המידע
אבל ה-circuit הוא יחידת החישוב
אז בואו ננסה להבין מה זה quantum circuit
ונסתכל על המבנה שלו
כך נראה quantum circuit
הוא מורכב מחלקים — ה-qubits
מיוצגים על ידי הקווים האופקיים האלה, במקרה הזה אנחנו מציגים
circuit עם ארבעה qubits שאתם רואים
פה עכשיו, ה-gates הם
האופן שבו אנחנו שולטים ב-qubits
וקוראים את ה-gates משמאל לימין
ה-gates של qubit בודד יכולים להיות
gates של qubit בודד או gates של מספר qubits
שם אתם רואים את ה-gate המבוקר
שהוא זה שיש לו קו בין שניים מה-qubits
ושם פעולת ה-entangling הולכת להתרחש
ולבסוף יש לכם את המדידה והפלט הקלאסי
וחשוב מאוד — אתם מריצים circuit הרבה פעמים
כדי לקבל את התוצאה עם מושג ה-shots
אז מונה ה-shots הוא מספר הפעמים
שצריך לחזור על החישוב כדי לקבל את התוצאה
טוב
איך הם נראים
בואו נסתכל איך נראה circuit של שני bits
זו הייתה התמונה מקודם, נכון — מציגה שינוי פאזה
והראיתי קודם פעולה שביצעה את הסיבוב הזה
שמאפשר לבצע את פעולת ה-interference
אז בואו נעשה השוואה בין circuit קלאסי
ל-quantum circuit — ב-circuit קלאסי
אפשר לראות שלא רואים ירח כחול, נכון
אין סיבובים, הכל כאן ורוד
ויש לכם מצבים בודדים
שב-gates האלה ראינו חלונות
אבל שימו לב לאיזה ניגוד הולך להיות
כשאנחנו באמת מממשים quantum circuit
אלה הם ה-circuits האמיתיים שאנחנו מריצים במחשבים הקוונטיים שלנו
שגם אתם יכולים לנסות
ה-circuits שאנחנו הולכים ליצור
עם שילוב ה-gates
מייצרים את האמפליטודה המורכבת המלאה
התמונה ששיתפתי אתכם
קודם — למה זה חשוב
כי עכשיו אנחנו יכולים ליצור את הקשרים המורכבים האלה
בין ה-qubits מבחינת פאזות
ו-entanglement, ואז דרך פעולת המדידה
אנחנו מסוגלים לקרוס את הכמות העצומה הזו
של חישוב שקורה בפנים, אל תוך
תשובה חשובה כלשהי
וכך אנחנו מגיעים בסופו של דבר אל
התשובה — אז אם נשים אותם זה לצד זה רק ויזואלית
אפשר לקבל תחושה ש-circuit קלאסי לעולם לא יוכל
לנצל את המרחב החישובי העצום
שיש ל-quantum circuit — זה
הכי טוב שאפשר לתת לכם את האינטואיציה הזו
על העושר שבו אנחנו יכולים לגשת למרחב המצבים הגדול הזה.
והחלק היפה בזה הוא שאנחנו יכולים
לקבל סוגים רבים של circuits שעושים
פונקציות שונות — אז
לדוגמה, זה circuit
שתוכנן לדגמל סיכון פיננסי
הנה דוגמה ל-circuit
שמשמש לחיפוש ואופטימיזציה של בעיות
והנה דוגמה ל-circuit שמשמש
לסימולציה של מולקולה — מסקנה
חשובה היא שאפשר לתכנן circuits שונים
לאפליקציות שונות
ה-circuits שאנחנו מתכננים נשמרים
בתוכנה ומוחזקים כתוכנה
ובמקרה שלנו אנחנו שומרים אותם ב-Qiskit
שהוא ערכת הפיתוח בקוד פתוח שלנו לחישוב קוונטי
זו אחת מסביבות התוכנה הנפוצות ביותר
לחישוב קוונטי
ואפשר לדמיין לבנות
ספריות של circuits שמוטמעות ב
תוכניות קלאסיות שמשלבות עכשיו את הטוב שבתכנות הקלאסי
ואת הטוב שבעוצמה הקוונטית